hey this is presh talwalkar
a statistician keeps a simple wardrobe
he only purchases pairs of black socks
and white socks and he keeps all of the
socks in a pile in the drawer
recently one of the socks was lost in
the laundry
the socks now have a mathematical
property
if you select two socks at random from
the drawer the socks will match in color
exactly fifty percent of the time
the statistician owns more than 200
socks but less than 250 socks and there
are more black socks than white socks
how many socks of each color are there
and which color sock was lost in the
laundry can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we can solve this problem by drawing a
tree of the possible ways to draw socks
on the first draw you could draw a black
sock or you could draw a white sock
suppose there are b black socks and w
white socks
suppose you drew a black sock
on the next draw you could draw another
black sock
since you've already pulled out one
black sock from the drawer
there is one fewer black sock remaining
so there are b minus one black socks
that this could have been from
if we multiply these two numbers b times
b minus one we get the total number of
ways that we could have drawn two black
socks in a row
on the second draw we could have also
drawn a white sock
there would have been w white socks
remaining in the drawer and if we
multiply b times w we get the number of
ways that we could pick a black sock on
the first draw and a white sock on the
second draw
now let's consider the the branch if we
drew a white sock
we could then draw a black sock
there are b black socks remaining
if we multiply w and b we get b w which
is the number of ways that we could get
a white sock and then a black sock
we could also have picked out a white
sock on the second draw
since we've already picked one white
sock there are w minus one white socks
remaining
if we multiply these two numbers we get
w times w minus one is the number of
ways to pick two white socks in a row
so how does this help us solve the
problem
we know that if we pick two socks we are
told the probability that these two
socks will match is equal to fifty
percent
since socks can either be matching or
not matching that means the probability
of picking two socks which are not
matching in color is also equal to fifty
percent therefore the probability of
picking a matching pair is equal to the
probability of picking a not matching
pair
in other words the number of ways to
pick two socks which match in color
equals the number of ways to pick two
socks which do not match in color
we figured out the number of ways from
the tree of possibilities that we've
just drawn out
so how many ways are there to pick two
socks which match
when we pick two black socks there's b
times b minus one ways and when we pick
two white socks it's w times w minus one
ways so the total number of ways to pick
two socks which match is the sum of
these two quantities
the remaining possibilities
are for when we pick two socks which do
not match in color
this will be equal to two bw
we can now simplify this equation and we
end up with b minus w the quantity
squared is equal to b plus w
now we need to deduce some things from
what we know about the total number of
socks
this equation tells us that the total
number of socks b plus w is a perfect
square
we know this because b plus w is equal
to the quantity b minus w squared
furthermore
we are told in the problem that the
total number of socks is between 200 and
250.
we can then consider which perfect
squares are between 200 and 250
and the only possibility is 15 squared
equals 225
so we figured out the total number of
socks is equal to 225
we also know the quantity b minus still
b squared is equal to 15 squared
this implies that either b minus w is
equal to 15 or w minus b is equal to 15.
but we can conclude b minus w is equal
to 15 because we were given that there
are more black socks than there were
white socks
so we have a system of equations which
we can then solve for the two variables
b and w
if we add up these two equations and
divide by two we get that b is equal to
a hundred and twenty
we then know there are fifteen more
black socks than white socks and
therefore the number of white socks is
equal to a hundred and five
so we figured out the number of socks of
each color
and we can now figure out which sock was
lost in the laundry
since the statistician only buy socks
and pairs
it must be the case
that pairs of socks would be a total
number that's an even number
but the number of white socks is odd
therefore we know that the missing sock
must have been the white sock
did you figure out this problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description